everybody was going on play here welcome
to stream Coco yes not today you'll
notice we are up here in our illustrious
conference room this is where stream
Coco started is up here this is also
where we first started playing clueless
gamers which is great and I'm so happy
we don't shoot clueless gamers up here
anymore because every single time we
shot a clueless gamer we had to move
this massive table out of the way you
see this thing look at this beast thing
weighs like 19,000 pounds so yes now we
shootin the insert stage and it's all
good thank you for joining us today we
are gonna play Assassin's Creed origins
look at this bad boy right here look at
this look at that that's a pyramid right
yeah it's I think those are called
pyramids Assassin's Creed origins that
you might have seen possibly us playing
on the last clues gamer with as I call
him the lesser Aaron Aaron Rogers just
kidding
he's more accomplished than I will ever
be and super nice of him and David
bakhtiari to come in and play Assassin's
Creed origins with us but you know what
we didn't really get to play I didn't
really get to play as much as I wanted
so we're gonna play this it is out now
so pop up up up up up pick it up let's
get into it shall we
so yes something extremely cool that you
won't actually maybe don't know is I
went to Egypt when I was younger and
they hired a lot of Egyptologists is
that what they're called
okay then I don't know what they're
called but experts on ancient Egypt
doing this game to put this game
together so this is incredibly
historically accurate which is amazing
and what you would expect from the
Assassin's Creed franchise but what's
weird is now when you go to Egypt like I
thought the Pyramids of Giza would be
out far away from everything you know
like like in this game like kind you
know in in the desert but
it's not it's all everything is kind of
built up around the pyramids which is
super weird and then there's this kind
of like what I'm trying to say is you
can sit in a McDonald's and look at the
Great Pyramid of Giza which is a little
weird
in Egypt so I'm very excited to play
this game because this is the Egypt I
imagine serious hey big boss 2222 how's
it going
yes here's the thing with clueless
gamers you know Conan likes to have a
slub there he doesn't want to just I
think maybe he's a little bit
intimidated by my looks
possibly by my smell because I smell
great so he's he's really into having
he's really into having celebrities in
the clothes gamers but maybe one day
soon it'll be Conan and I again hey miss
- its what's up yes yes Madeline Sims
good to see you hey tan Ramirez what's
going on oh yeah in our system right
this game it looks incredible but it's
our streaming in our system which is why
any kind of artifacts you see are the
the things we have to do the pipes we
have to send all this stuff through it
can be kind of small so as many of you
can enjoy it as possible this brings you
crazy then a lot of you won't be able to
but yes what I'm seeing right now is
beautiful yes that's right Strangelove
it's so surreal to see this on the Conan
Channel that's true and that's the
effect I normally have on people is sir
reality I hope everybody had a great
Halloween I want everybody in this dream
- oh maybe we got some fighting here I'm
gonna have to kick somebody's ass hip
toasts are hip a as I call him for short
I don't want to skip I'm gonna beat this
guy's ass
also why would you as a big guy in
ancient Egypt why would you have a face
mask it's so hot I know what I'm saying
I love any tutorial that lets me just
kick everybody's ass you know mm-hmm
you know maybe here's an idea a big
bodyguard guy maybe don't choose a giant
80 pound mace you know oh wait I hate
those sinkholes you know the worst what
everybody what did you guys dressed up
as for Halloween and then I'm gonna tell
you what I dressed up as and I have a
great story of course because my life is
a and nightmare and be completely insane
hello Oh Halloween oh god what's
happening here oh boy it's a pot of sea
exactly oh boy this dude is real tall do
you think this guy is like lifts in his
shoes maybe he's actually only like 5 -
and he's really you know he's super
insecure about his height yeah dude it
is gonna be a fight to the death
guess who's death guess whose death is
gonna I guess that who's gonna get
killed in this let me in case you're
curious it's not Popeye toast or hip
toast that's on the box it's me
by I could see why
my name
and of course obviously you know I love
why would i equip that weapon a heavy
blunt or as I call it Emily Blunt after
two mini doughnuts look for the scarabs
friend look for the scarabs pass through
the crack alone so ooh somebody went is
Cho Gianna went as chun-li Darren wood
is Dave Grohl that's great one of our
co-workers actually his children go to
school at Dave joke the girl girls
children I was like that's awesome just
seeing Dave girl dropping his kids off
although maybe here's that here's the
other thing is you know never meet your
heroes you know what if Dave go all he's
pulling up listening to Enya you know
like I don't know maybe I you know I
love Indian girl Dave girl you can
listen to whatever you want
oh you're the best grizzly bear thank
you what else did you guys go out one
thing I love about Assassin's Creed is
the parkour because I'm incredibly
inflexible and have bad knees I could
never do this in real life so when I see
bike jumping off stuff
all right you guys want to hear a crazy
story about Halloween now let me just
preface this by saying I don't look for
weird stuff to happen okay I don't
it just happens to me I don't know what
to say everyone is always it's just I'm
like a weird magnet I'm like a magnet
for weirdness okay anyway so I went as I
had a bit of a last minute cosmic Ahsan
crisis okay now look Halloween is my
favorite holiday I'd like to do it up
big look at this see this is what I'm
talking about I wish I could do this man
I just don't have like the knees or the
finger strength that's a big belly
button get away from that thing oh yeah
more ass kicked across so all right
here's your beak ah here's the bee
costume story Madeline
so basically uh let me just hold on I
feel like I have to show you guys before
this guy could take care of himself for
a second I need to show you this bee
costume all right so I had kind of a
last-minute freak out
because Halloween is my favorite holiday
and I was gonna go as Juno Mars
you know like Bruno Mars but the
pregnant girl from Juno kind of a mashup
and there was too many things I couldn't
figure it out so instead I was with my
friend Megan and she picked out this bee
costume now this is the bee costume
right here can you see it there's the
bee costume there we go all right now I
didn't realize this so I'm going to this
house party Saturday night
Oh what's up sucka get into it don't
forget to dodge
I think that's justice we'll make sure
of that
who's got a shield who's got a bad
haircut
you know hold on I'm gonna release my
full power that works hey pal so I'm
walking to this party by myself through
my super hip neighborhood feeling kind
of self-conscious and as I'm walking
people start saying hey Blind Melon
Blind Melon right I'm like I guess I
look like The Blind Melon b-girl now if
you google Blind Melon b-girl I don't
look anything like her but I think it
was like they liked the skirt the black
skirt that my friend Megan picked out so
Phil thanks Megan for nothing what and
I'm like I guess I'm just come on me
girl I'm not but whatever and I go to
this liquor store and these two guys are
coming out and the one guy go to kind of
scary-looking guys then we gotta go to
Blind Melon and I was like oh yeah you
got it man yep and I go to the counter
whatever I did some chop it and all of a
sudden and one of the guys has come back
in my best friend's sister I was like
what
he goes my best friend's sister I said
where's your mom what and he goes my
best friend's sister is the Blind Melon
b-girl what and I was like uh and I was
blown away and I was like oh he goes
yeah and I was like that's amazing is it
yeah that's like oh well how's she doing
he goes she's doing great and I tell her
she's an inspiration to me and he's like
I will happy Halloween he's like you too
and that's why we're living in an Elon
Musk computer simulation guys what the
heck
ridiculous so I thought that was like
totally nuts man like why does that I
feel like that stuff always happens to
me like it's just completely bananas one
thing I like about this game is you
could just hold X and then just
automatically follow the guy because I
gotta say I love Red Dead Redemption but
man sometimes we're going fast in that
horse you kind of like hit left and all
of a sudden you're in a tree that's a
mess so especially when you're doing now
when you're learnt when you're talking
to your old pal going back to your
hometown of c1 sometimes you just want
to chill out you know this is this is
the original Google auto driving car as
what's happening here it's the auto
driving camel it's pretty dope
how can he sister you the B girl and my
sisters to be girl it's not his sister
it's his best friend's sister so maybe
you're his best friend I have not seen
the new season of stranger things what
do we think what do you think I hear
good things this is great
Auto driving camel man I think we all
need a lot I've been playing the crap
out of game it's pretty addictive this
game is super that's great about this
game is it's huge and they have a ton of
awesome side quests like one of the
things I love like clothes gamer is
great and I love clueless gamer
but you know we only have X amount of
minutes to put on the air because we got
to talk to celebrities and have a band
on our show I keep pushing for our show
to go - OH
solid clueless gamer for now but anyway
so we only we have to cut stuff out and
so I think actually we're going to
release more gameplay with Aaron Rodgers
and stuff because there was just really
funny stuff that we just couldn't fit
into the
it's the gamer but but yeah so that's
why there's a ton of great side quests
that really fun stranger things season 2
mikela straightening season 2 is all
good except for episode 7 I'm driving
that's the secret prize that Google is
getting a patent on as we speak I love
the idea of like do the Google engineers
playing this game and being like how can
we get a camel to auto drive Ubisoft has
done it man for you guys yeah and Shaun
you make a good point the quests
actually give you stuff you would
actually want now rather than just being
pointless like so many side quests are
like excuse me pardon me excuse me
camels by the way I don't know if
anybody's ever ridden a camel here but
they are super tall and really scary to
ride because they kind of sit down and
how they get up because they have four
knees is they get up by they go like and
then forward and you feel like you're
just gonna fall off hang on to those
humps man those humps those humps what
if my camel needs a tow that's a good
question
what do you get to tell a camel I've no
idea I mean I know I understand your
joke I get it leave your mom you
actually took it as a serious question
because what happened episode 7 was a
bottle episode that felt like a cliche
super8 episode at a place that's
interesting I think it's less less weird
that they did a bottle episode and more
weird that they didn't I know feels like
a pretty pretty high budget show I think
whenever you do anything
stuff you know what let's hold on a
second I do like me some subtitles I'm
not gonna lie all I do like me some
subtitles papa fight damage on of course
when my fool when I have freaking fool
language where we had subtilis play on
please grand theft camel doing all them
side missions fall and jaemin Hector
hour-long clues camera Cal maybe you
never know you never know we certainly
we certainly can do it
Conan has no qualms about talking about
video games and his stream of
consciousness he's a lot to say he's the
o Brahma choco heron do you ever hang
out with Andy I've seen Andy twice today
already somewhat sit Starbucks and oh my
god I'll beat up in lie dude I'm so
messed up what's going on maybe I've
just been painting my apartment I mean I
don't nobody wants to hang out with me I
would like to hang out with Andy I hung
out with Andy at a wedding once was
really fun it is great so it's cold
those guys are dope I spent five hours
in the car with Conan and one of our
writers Mike Sweeney on last Friday when
he made an appearance at twitchcon that
was a lot of Conan time it was great and
then we hung out in the bar afterwards
is very fun yep come on you know play me
like this Holmes you gonna play me like
this
four hours in the wreck over yeah boy me
like that
hey rosewood why not be nice
what's the point like what are we doing
anymore how you take a lot out of it
does uh yellow flash yes you can 100%
hang out with me would win a fight Conan
or McGregor come on dude
Gregor would win in a heartbeat no it's
funny so we did a close game Rosanna
McGregor first of all nicest dude oh by
the way everyone we've done clueless
gamer with isn't super super nice what's
super interesting to me I was actually
just having this conversation with
somebody about the athletes that we've
done Tom Brady Aaron Rodgers Marshawn
Gronk
von Miller Josh Norman and of course
Conor McGregor is they are so chill and
cool like and it's I was especially
struck by Conor McGregor because this is
a guy who took care of this beats people
up for a lid
you know just destroys people for a
living
oh I'm on it don't worry pal yeah I get
it dude let's take him down oh no come
on elbow do the throat I just spit on
the camera he's still alive dude Conor
McGregor's so and all these efforts are
so chill it's amazing like and it's kind
of crazy because how much we'll just
feel like how intense they must be on
the field or in the ring versus how they
are off you know out of the ring and
just in normal life and Conor was like
the cool and the nicest dude ever like
you know for a guy who like talks trash
and all that stuff nicest dude ever
super chill and he came in in fuzzy
slippers and we did a thing where I
thought it'd be funny to have Conan to
have Conor you know like do some moves
on Conan and he just he's like ability
to control his body is crazy first of
all he's solid as a rock second of all
posture amazing just like incredible you
can only see the top part of my shoulder
here
I'm eight like totally like amazing
straight back and then you just move so
fluidly like a dancer really really
interestingly and when he faked kicked
Conan in the face when he about to kick
coming the face I mean he brought his
foot like right here and it was just
unbelievable like and it was never never
even an issue you know it's just these
guys are just on another level you kind
of like forget like for those guy like
you watched you know whatever like you
watch football you're like oh yeah I
could do that whatever it like the level
these guys operate at is just
otherworldly I mean part of it is just
genetics you could never be there's a
great foster Walt Foster Wallace I can't
believe I'm talking about David Foster
Wallace I'm sure there's a great David
Foster Wallace book you all should read
called the supposedly fun thing I'll
never do again and it's all it's all
short essays and David Foster Wallace
played semi-pro tennis and so it's an
essay all about tennis and what it takes
to get to that level and hot like the
journeyman of tennis you know there's
obviously you know you're Serena
Williams at least these people who are
at the top of their level who play only
the big tournaments but to make a living
elders to make a living in this as a
tennis pro you need to play all the time
in every tournament you can and just the
rigorous amount of practice it takes and
the rigorous amount of playing and all
that stuff and then how you'll just
never be able to get to Serena's level
just because you're not born with those
genetics they're really interesting
really interesting point he makes and it
kind of opened my eyes to the world I
also watch Hard Knocks is a great show
on HBO I love like I've been sneaking
around knocking people out my friend is
just hanging out on some pillows in the
thing like bro help me out yeah Wallace
is great scream while talking about
tennis tennis sorry I can do so you are
telling me you do not have the powers of
a god but the real problem is that man
you want to do one thing that I think is
always tough and one thing I love about
Assassin's Creed origins right it's hard
when you're making a game or I would
imagine it's pretty
just came back from a blacklight rave
that spins [ __ ]
sure bender damn I can make that myself
weapons are more difficult the soldiers
took everything in the village I will
talk to the blacksmith yes everybody is
such a cool name in the same but one of
the things I think was a sonorous does
really well which is hard to do for a
game is I mean let us make an ancient
weapons exciting and there's a lot of
Awesome crazy weapons you can find
legendary weapons you can unlock there's
a bow that shoots five arrows at once
which is badass up here comes my eagle
yeah baby just starts pecking out of
here Oh pecking out his eyeball how
jealous is my friend of my my eat my
bike and send you the Eagles
relationship
yes son that's me just farting all my
scarves all right hold options Detroit
oh well your quest available a perfect I
think this is a good screen for me to be
on hit the wrong button the false Oracle
mean cup I need to hunt for leather
crafting materials you know what I don't
want to do this instead I'm gonna I'm
gonna track a different thing
false Oracle man let's do it I say let's
try it let's just try it you know let's
do it man it's a video game that's the
best thing I'm going for it I know I'm
supposed to be level 5 but I'm gonna get
so own right as this serious ever really
addressed the aliens angle well question
your favorite of all of the brass
knuckles in Assassin's Creed city game I
do love me some brass knuckles ooh ham
famous no autographs please guys I'm
just trying to go kill the Ibis let's do
it yeah I got a problem
here's the thing man scoping out stuff
is so important in this game that's the
whole it's the whole issue
it's like these guys never get wise to
the fact that like my Eagles doing all
my dirty work I'm feeling a little
rumble a little rumble I'm so bad it
inverted I try so it I would play this
old game called Tarak dinosaur hunter I
got to change the I gotta change the
inverted I'm sorry and and there's the
options and that and so I learned how to
play inverted and then I would play a
ton of Halo and all that stuff and what
I want here make gaming you guys want to
see me go through menus and so that I
had four clueless gamer I had to switch
and I had to relearn how to play not
inverted because Conan is so bad I just
couldn't deal with it okay that target I
can't do can I do a lot of recon here
a lot of level fives right here so you
know fools rush in but why not Tarak his
legend Tarak was super fun
exactly just the Eagles inverted yeah
yet Tarak Taraki Tarak man
but yeah so I I just played hours upon
yeah it's me dude no it's another
awesome handsome dude climbing the wall
by a [ __ ] okay everyone just relax all
right
yeah I wish people like this in real
life - thanks Mauro this guy should get
on bumble man be pickin up right and
left you know if I was in this world I
would definitely put my ex picture as my
profile picture on global I mean I guess
also smartphones that have to exist
there's a lot that would have to happen
I guess for that to go down first they'd
have to so dude in trouble all right
let's just see I just want to see how
far I can get I'm level two three levels
are not that much you see that dude
Oh
now as a warrior I think walking around
without a shirt on his foolish I'm just
gonna put that out there
oh [ __ ] it's on now damn oh I don't have
any oh I know health Oh get me out of
here oh I got desync oh my god
all right
three levels in this game is definitely
like you know fighting two levels above
but three is hard to sell you know what
challenge accepted started Devi
challenge accepted
I think I might just need a little more
recon you know recons the key man we
kind of the key to this game if you're
planning on becoming an assassin in each
of Egypt I highly recommend training an
eagle super smart right there relieving
oh that's a nice way of saying it
all right we got arrows over there oh my
god there's so many dudes in this thing
right I'm not scared
he's giant damn big Rams over there
Gyptians were really into their statues
you know
pretty good
it's all about stealth baby
there's no time limit on this right now
there's
I forgot I don't have any health that's
the other thing is like when we play
clothes gamer a lot of times a lot of
times they'll hook me up with they'll
hook me up with like a lot of health or
whatever we I'm not even stabbing them
yet that's the hook we have a lot of
health so I don't have to start at the
very beginning
hit and run baby hit and run the tool of
any great assassin I can kill affair on
his bed really I don't get the hidden
blades I get hey what
cool stay down there how to care later
are you gonna hop up here oh I need I
don't have the hidden blade these guys
are everywhere
they are on my ass damn all right let's
go chop it Oh help if I hit him with the
sword first take your time with those
hits bro
hey man he just wants to run some stuff
past his wife it's cool takedown yeah
let's just knock him out yeah it's me
dude the famous bike alright get out of
here
Oh she'll break dude why don't you just
leave you're getting your ass kicked
over oh Jesus
sorry would you grease I just freed why
are you hanging around man let's go hit
and run so a little my health is coming
back so awesome hands like a flick doom
in Skyrim VR they're out next month
ooh we streaming the other one that's a
good question I'd love to I'd be super
fun hey Mario Odyssey gigolo puff
I just bought a switch over the weekend
I've been playing wery Odyssey it's
great super fun all right now
would like to check this out but I don't
want to die
I think it'd be sweet if you could get
sin eating like fly inside of buildings
how dope would that be a little Hawk
just like hopping around little eagle
guy not flying just like walking I'm
gonna talk to the developers we'll see
if we can get that going all right I
gotta kill this mofo oh that's him right
there
oh he's over this way all right
very quietly
fine typical management what happened to
the priest I wanted it question by Swamp
priests like it's that easy
hey didn't do a stealth attack dude holy
oh my god two hits oh boy oh that was
very depressing damn it I did so well
alright I do love this though they like
the matrix room please remember
Assassin's Creed games these are all
virtual simulations like my current life
with as The Blind Melon yes
all right let's go up the side Oh should
I send you it what do you think yeah bro
I'm coming at ya this dude over here
[Music]
those guys are dicks ok another hawk
fleeing a fleeing hawk good to know
I think what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna
go straight in man you know just rated
enough of this fizzle Faisal you know
love this Rudy do enough this coupe name
numbers razzamatazz you know
why as an assassin why do I need to go
after everybody I don't just kill let's
kill jerkwater
okay
help anything
oh now I'm the weeds dumb in the weeds
cuz you won't see anything you would see
the weeds movie at all here we go
Oh see this is I feel pretty safe in
undercover here off the side oh you know
what they should have looks like a
gardener look like they've been trying
to save money on a gardener it's gonna
cost us duties of life always pay your
gardener that way us assassins can't
sneak in wreck shop
this guy's finger strength is incredible
you must use those like Chinese balls or
something for grip strength you can
never have too much hootenanny no I
agree more hootenanny the better I say
all right here's the problem I think
what I'm gonna need to do is just drop
down from above and just kill the dude
got him what no I guess I can't
stealth-attack him up all right
Oh
bring it
oh this is very bad Oh son Oh Metal Gear
Osiris Sphinx of Liberty thank God for
open roofs this is avery
yeah that's their mistake you know guys
open never do an open roof I need to be
his level
Oh to it I seek attack them okay fair
enough all right fine then we'll do this
other mission quick prisoners in the
temple level four I could do that easy
peasy not a problem on level four
gotcha because your boys level two what
am i a noob nope
I'm whatever next to a noob is post noob
I'm just past being a noob postiive I
think is a good phrase
howdy fellas
where am I going are we going come on
boys sinew is somewhere over here in the
trees there we go got him
now remember this way now there's a lot
of priests so I didn't realize there's
so many oh man God
oh there's five priests that feels like
a lot of priests fair enough
you know what no task is too big no
tasks is too small unless it was the
task that I just tried to do which case
is way too big I'm not gonna pay for
anything you know it's pretty
disrespectful to call me corpse I'm a
living person
everybody just go protect your dude all
right
crawling this big RAM but ie
howdy fellas good to see ya oh wow okay
damn right for the kidney that seemed
like a bit of overkill
pretty lame oh pretty lame oh you know
what maybe the levels are important in
this game I love the idea of byuk
putting all this stuff on every morning
all right
each scarf hold on I'm almost ready
honey like the Opera starting what they
go to the Opera just a thousand straps
all right let's just do what you know
what we're gonna I need to I need to get
a quick win under my belt here feeling
pretty low I need to hunt for leather
but hunting for leathers so I don't want
to do it let me just try one more
prisoners in the temple I think I could
do it
level four dudes are kind of tough I
love like I was just kicking like level
42 ass before guys you got it you know i
torch is on my hands
go
wait a minute you saw nothing
Oh leave this rug he be some one of
those in my house
so you throw them off a bit I do like
how the guys are still tagged that's
really nice
sneak around
right blow yourself no sense of false
security I say wait where's the guy
right
man whoo nice library
it's asleep
anybody in here
well yeah got you boy be quiet dude now
please leave not like these other tools
get out of here Holmes
ah mojito yeah I kind of agree like it
would be nice if the other dudes
couldn't climb like I can just because
then it would be easier for me to get
out of here let's keep these dudes you
know maybe ever everyone is just very
fit back then there weren't any cars
they're only self-driving camels you
know back in ancient Egypt I just pass
them a special loot chest where where's
the special loot chest dude it's back
over here if I get killed because of
this we're gonna have words
Geoff Kay all right I'm looking for the
special loot chest I'm not into the
chests man do I need to get the loot
chest
these guys are super loud all right just
better not get me caught dude
or was it it's hard because they're too
this is it right yes there we go
dude it up alright thank you Jeff I'm
sorry I think it's the next one that
looks tough this dude over here I see
this dude once right oh it gives me XP
every time I find one there we go I'm
bad Jeff k looking out for me what does
everybody else in the Chad done for me
today nothing Jeff Kate hooking me up
with extra XP as I call it X XP
thank you I have to say one of my
biggest pet peeves about games is not
knowing where to go I feel like this
game is super clear all the Assassin's
Creed games are really clear about where
to go
because nothing kills the vibe more like
for instance like oh yes sneaky sneaky
all right get out of here bro don't
alert them to my presence you all right
yeah [ __ ] shake a tailfeather friend
all right here we go all right we're
doing good we're doing good three out of
five we only got two left it's gonna be
tough though see who needs to be level
four you know level two it up man
believe in yourself that's my theme of
today's stream guys doesn't matter if
your level to be a level believe you're
a for believing yourself choose your
finger will oh all right here we go that
reference is probably way too old for
most of you guys oh god no please let me
jump wrong I jumped wrong home I jumped
wrong please get me up there
oh god oh no
yeah oh I thought that the dead that did
it and then see here fellas
howdy fellas all right guys remember
like when I was super tough about the
guy not mowing his lawn and then I
immediately got killed
oops oh there's a level 2 guy see every
level is like a puzzle y'all there's a
thousand ways to do every mission arrow
[Music]
okay what about that oh here we go
they're leaving ah yes patience friend
patience yeah go on get out of here
later actually I want to tag this dude -
real quick just gonna continue straight
at the wall yes we did it dude haha
later suckers boom who's he level four
please oh yeah now I just need to get
out of here that dying do a little slack
line on my way out you know like a
circus performer done skis I'm telling
you man never never underestimate what
sneaking can do in this game
you know it just for fun just to
celebrate I'm gonna take this dude down
oh I guess I can't though right cuz I'm
too nice for see this is where this is
where I get cocky and things go wrong
boom you gotta let him know you're you
were here you know or what's the point
yes so I'm talking about now I could be
a jerk and trying to this my I think I
need to be at least level 3 I think now
let's go over here let's investigate
some other stuff it's color camel
Oh Auto camel that's a good name for a
camel
Mel Mel the camel camel
yes Conan's my hero you're exactly right
Conan is merely a puppet he's a hologram
that I control actually not really
that's probably the other way around I'm
thinking about it I sometimes wonder in
my life which is a depressing thought if
I've written
Conan's name more or I've written my
name more I'm gonna probably say Conan's
name cuz when I was video researcher I
had to fill out all these requests and I
always have to write Late Night with
Conan O'Brien inside right and I had to
do it like five times a day whereas like
when am I gonna write my name for my
rent check
JT today by the way so thanks for
reminding me stream bye old men out to
post your camels are Roach that's good I
have post
who Assassin's Creed Russia would be fun
what about like during the Cold War
wouldn't that be awesome in the 50 oh my
god
oh boy whoops okay well at least this
dude who's only one level above me
oh he's this dude like serious though
man oh damn oh Jesus all right
what now son oh damn seven
Thank You Luke bird I know I know you
love me
Assassin's Creed
uh yeah like kind of like an atomic
blonde maybe like you guys ever seen
that movie it'd be sweet and like there
was an assassin's creed that was kind of
like atomic blonde or it was like I
guess that took place in the 80s right
that was more like actually it's
completely different that's Germany in
the eighties the guys just got just
watching me like what's this going on
over here
give me that hawk or give me the eagle
action Eagle Eye baby
you know I'm telling you guys a little
scope you know you got to you got to
practice like you play and you got to
play well so you just got a uh you know
the Recon goes a long way where's that
fat dude with the club that I want to
destroy now it's personal baby
never take your eyes off the birdie
friend enjoy that elbow sauce sweet
sweet elbow sauce yeah no [ __ ]
World War two Assassin's Creed would be
dope I agree super fun come on over pal
I like your hair do you well now this
guy's this tall grass guys pay your
gardeners I'm telling you right now mow
your lawns sneaking around at will over
here
maybe all these guys got sick all of a
sudden maybe it was the stew maybe it
was the stew or maybe it's I'm gonna
start using that at bar so I need to get
get to the bar to get a drink I go
excuse me ah just guys just fall I did
one time I was in a bit on the show a
long time ago and I had to look beat up
and so I just left the makeup on and
went out to a bar nothing will get you
to the bar faster than looking like you
were just in a crazy flight everybody
leaves you alone it's pretty great
well well what do we have here he's
standing on the table thank you let's
interact do you move this I don't you
know here's the thing I love backstories
and I'll oh yeah give me that chest
waiting about this Jeff Jeff Kay but I
don't need it you know I want action
when I play games for real I am very
into the story I play games on the
stream man it's entertainment you know
gotta give you guys what you want now
this dude I can't take him down right
you take that down no way oh yeah and
that's a tough now are you
that got Oh sickle sword what hey I'm
definitely equipping this sickle sir
whoever just said hey is gonna be the
first guy to feel the business end of
this sickle sword here we go oh hell yes
Oh sexy excuse me worm yeah I don't
think so pal it slices it dices it makes
julienne fries it's this sickle sword oh
yeah oh so close to level three guys I'm
so close I can taste it
there another dude over here I just
wanted him get down and get funky on I
do love quest but like these games are
just so fun like the worlds are just
insane I love to do yeah oh hey I like
your straight dork sword
nice to sword fork with a sickle sword I
love I use the hooks hook is face oh my
god oh jeez that's great you know what
insult meat injury leer by E that's
right oh yeah oh that was great
blood squirting out of them if you love
me just dropping bodies that's my movies
I'll just drop a body off a cliff just
no respect
you know it's all about a mind game and
when people come across your handiwork
you got to be like this is Bayaka see
wad don't f with that dude
he's got a camel name cut comb comb oh
that's terrible
I'm gonna call it a better name about
Annie my camel darkness that's pretty
scary
please start blocking yes sorry I will
say I'm sure it's super annoying
don't play games how I play them because
I'm terrible video games that's the real
secret close gamer I'm also bad Hey yes
guys we're almost done with this dream I
just want to kill one more dude at my
awesome sickle sword Oh see that icon
means they've lit the fire I want to
call it a brazier but I think that's
what a woman wears for reinforcements so
these dudes are all guys who who have
been called the reinforcements
reinforcements squad
which means they gonna die oh you know
what I haven't used my phone and oh yeah
sweet little head shot you know what
let's end on the head shot cuz I'm about
to get massacred here guys thank you for
joining us for today's jib Koko I hope
you had a blast this is a special
episode of American Conference Room
the game is Assassin's Creed origins it
is out now you could place by active see
wha and just kick everybody's ass I
gotta say sickle sword favorite things
so far pretty badass as well as camel
and hope you guys enjoyed it we are
going to New York next week so make sure
to watch our week of shows from the
Apollo
starting Monday night with a whole bunch
of crazy amazing guests it's gonna be a
lot of fun of course with a bunch of new
york-style comedy you know the pizza is
thinner the jokes are hard here what can
I say the laughs are Hardy or the pizza
is thinner oh my god O'Malley hates that
joke thank you all for joining us
Sanskrit word just go get it and we'll
see you guys next time later
[Music]
you